bienvenue une surrender dogs le podcast
envergure qui comme son nom l'indiqué
vous présentent les profils de joueurs
qui ne font pas la une sur espn mais qui
pourrait avoir une belle carrière en
étant drafté en fin de second tour voire
non drafté on cherche les frais de vente
bit ly daniel gillet marc gasol nikola
djokic patty mills et tant d'autres
underdogs c'est un podcast produit par
la date at-il d'envergure nous sommes
sept et à chaque podcast trois d'entre
nous vous vous présentez un prospect de
son choix et de la zone dont il s'occupe
monde europe ou conférencier en guest on
accueille un membre d'envergure potes
qui donnera un avis point de vue sur
chaque prospect
les présentations sont faites c'est
parti salut à tous bienvenue pour un
nouvel épisode de dirt 2 heures au
programme de prospection et un prospère
européen passé par le collège basketball
et la désormais traditionnelle et
presque fameuse carte blanche de la vie
telle envergure
pour ce faire j'accueille mes compères
de la data team notre big three maison
composée de pierre hugues et julien mes
hommages messieurs bonsoir a choisi sert
pour ce quatrième épisode
invité exceptionnel il est l'heureux
papa du podcast envergure donc en temps
vous dire qu'on a un peu la pression
vous connaissez pour sa voix et ses
questions ciselé lors des podcasts mais
aussi pour son magnifique ou digbeu
zagat qu'il arbore lors de ses passages
chez nos collègues de la force s'ils
allaient levier est avec nous salut boss
salue l'équipe zéro pression les gars
vous êtes déjà excellent les
présentations sont faites
le carnet de notes est à portée de main
hundreds saison 1 épisode 4 c'est parti
[Musique]
pierre directs sont l'europe pour un
prospect que l'on connaît bien l'acier
vu qu'il a passé deux ans à gonzaga
il s'agit de l'intérieur philippe et
rousseff c'est ça c'est ça le talent
qu'on a vu en 6ème et aussi un risque où
l' on a aux états unis donc au niveau
pas grande île est né en serbie
en 2000 il n'est pas ici d'une famille
de basketteurs donc il a dit que lui il
est tombé sur le basket comme ça parce
que j'étais grand est a appris la série
l'a pas mal pour les gays en europe
puisque là c'est les trois gros clubs de
de serbie donc il ya les cols rouges
partisans et beograd il me semble et
ensuite il a été repéré pendant un
tournoi européen par passe konya et donc
ils allaient faire si je me trompe pas
sa première année cadet dans les équipes
de jeunes à la fondation 511 et ensuite
il est allé rejoindre ses compères
servent aux états unis et dans le
connecticut je me suis un peu le nom du
lycée il a fait deux ans qu'il a
commises dans une petite fac d'éco vite
quand le coach a été viré donc il a
rejoint mon verde pour faire un arbre et
school et ensuite il a rejoint congas et
juste avant la date de 2020
il a inscrit son nom à tarte et il a
décidé leur rôle de le retirer de signer
pour mes gars
l'aic donc beggas soccer bête qui joue
en nba league qui est la ligue asiatique
est aussi en ligue 1 ça alors toi tu as
suivi la ligue de gatti et qu'est ce qui
a changé chez lui chez
chez philippe pitt rousseff depuis c'est
ce son temps à gonzaga
ouais alors ce qui est vraiment criant
qui est extrêmement criant c'est son
shoot voit lui-même il n'est pas dit il
s'en cache pas il le dit serrant skier
c'est un peu ce qu'ils vivent c'est
vraiment il a dit il a développé un
shoot à trois points il il est à 61 % de
réussite et il a 41 9 à trois points
allez je me suis pas née télé le nombre
de tentatives mais je crois qu'il est à
peu près à 3 3 3 et demie tentatives à
trois points par match ouais mais voilà
il allait il a vraiment les clés du
camion en fait avec son compère
simonovic est défensivement on
connaissait un petit peu joueurs
s'étaient pas forcément sa qualité
première est ce qu'il ya eu des progrès
sur ce côté là aussi alors ça j'ai
essayé d'en parler avec alan dans
l'équipe ya plusieurs prospects car si
mal comme case alors le français et lui
me disait qu'il y la vie de mme aubry
l'avait pas encore il n'avait pas encore
pu le voir mais que ce qui se
souvenaient ce n'était pas forcément
terrible à gonzaga il avait vraiment des
gros problèmes de vitesse latéral il se
fait prendre en fait surtout les départs
croisés il est incapable de contenir un
meneur cette année ça va un peu mieux il
défend sur pick'n roll toujours en drop
donc c'est peut-être un petit peu ça
veut peut-être dire qu'il n'est pas
encore capable de suivre meneur de le
2-2 complètement l'arrêter mais pour moi
ce n'est pas encore c'est pas un red
flag je les ai vus en équipe de jeunes
contre la france notamment ont touché ce
rallye où c'était franchement c'est
convenable donc turler scouting y pense
qu'on a publié aujourd'hui je les ai pas
mentionné parce que j'ai encore envie de
voir je suis pas sûr que sont red flag
mais ça va tu as deux gros ce que vous
en pensez
alexandre trauner et bien sûr si on
parle de la défense
moi ce que j'ai ce qui m'a frappé en le
regardant jouer c'était déjà le cas à
gonzaga mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment un bon défenseur sur drop dans
le sens où il parvient très bien à se
placer entre le joueur qui drive sur le
pick and roll et le joueur qui doit
défendre lui c'est à dire le mec qui
roule il a des bonnes mains il parvient
à anticiper à lire un petit peu le
l'intention de l'attaquant savoir s'il
va y avoir un lob silva plutôt aller au
panier etc
et du coup a compensé son manque de
protection de cercle grâce à cette
intelligence et cette vivacité
donc je trouve que c'est un bon
défenseur de drogue vraiment un bon
défenseur et al'inverse des qui met un
pied en dehors de la raquette pour moi
ça reste un îlot flag quand même des qui
met un pied en dehors de la raquette
c'est compliqué c'est à dire que soit il
va être trop loin et donc le gars peut
shooter sur sa tête
clairement soit il va trop trop
s'avancer il va se faire driver est
vraiment des qui défend sur un joueur
plus petits plus véloce
ce n'est que la ligue adriatique et il
se fait déjà bien souvent bien souvent à
voir donc défensivement moi je ne suis
pas même très sceptique sur sa capacité
à pouvoir peser vraiment nba mais alors
du coup la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est est-ce que
philippe et rousseff et plus ils veulent
cette année que l'année dernière avec un
an de plus moi je te dis oui pour ce
qu'a dit pierre sur le tir c'est à dire
que défensivement il n'a pas montré plus
mais il a confirmé parce qu'en fait
vraiment ce qu ils le regardaient jouer
savait qu'il pouvait tirer
il a juste reculé de 2 mètres mais la
mécanique elle est hyper propre ya aucun
problème sur sur le fait que je peux
personnellement j'avais assez peu de
doute sur le fait qu'il puisse shoot et
éventuellement à trois points et il l'a
prouvé l'a prouvé cette année mais oui
je pense qu'il est plus en tout cas
c'est plus facile de le faire jouer
rapidement parce que y'a pas besoin de
développer son shoot donc pour une
équipe nba c'est plus intéressant donne
de l'espoir pour lui pour la suite de sa
carrière ce qu'il a réussi à s'imposer
dans une ligue européenne de premier
plan on ne savait même pas avoir la
vision qu'il veut sur les 1 sur le la
différence entre un lancier l'europe la
ligue adriatique femme reconnue en
europe même s'il n'est pas dans une dans
une des premières équipes dans les
équipes de haut de tableau c'est le
leader de l'équipe c'est le leader dans
les chiffres
c'est lui qui utilisent qui a le plus le
ballon et donc il a prouvé vraiment que
c'était un professionnel ni l'a prouvé
il a montré qu'il s'était à ce coureur
il a montré ce qu'ils savaient faire ce
qui se sait sur quoi ils raisonnent il a
réussi à se développer et peut-être
qu'on n'en prend pas souvent mais il a
encore montré une capacité à s'adapter
je trouve que c'est quand même c'est
quand même bon point pour un joueur de
pouvoir traverser encore l'atlantique
est de passer d'un jeu américain un jeu
européen et va pouvoir traverser nattés
juin philippe et rousseff ça vous évoque
quelque chose
écoute
je trouve que ça alors toujours aussi
élégant quand on voit jouer la méga
soccer bête
il joue beaucoup et moi je trouve qu'il
est il est toujours sous contrôle quoi
malgré son gros temps de jeu il est sous
contrôle il a un bon moteur quoi il est
fait ce qu'il fallait faire et je pars
il fait pas de bêtise et comme a dit
pierre il est prouvé aux shoots sont
très encourageants je veux leur
talentueux en attaque
appliqués en défense mais limité on peut
se réduire comme ça en fait un truc
qu'on n'a pas du tout parlé c'est ça
qu'elle était de passe aussi à petric f
c'est que là cette année on a à quatre
passes décisives alors on dit pas que
c'est un magic johnson ou quoi que ce
soit mais que c'est que ça mais qui
comprend vraiment bien le jeu et ça
donne une value de plus tu en parles de
qi basket ça aussi ça c'est que
s'enfermer pas moi j'avais peur à
gonzaga que ce soit un gars qui domine
près du panier comme beaucoup de
attention enfin quoi qu intérieure en
niveau 1 ancien métier si t'as pas le
jeu pour croiser des bonnes vielles
alliant un tir qui avait dit à mi
distance qu'il a développée et ça ça lui
donne plus de plus de plus de value
parce que le pet food chef qui tirent
pas trois points par le draft pas à ce
corps en nba où il donnera pas de poste
bas tu vois à l'angola ont maintenant on
peut le faire jouer de différentes
manières et ça c'est hyper gens pourtant
prendre l'intérieur
drafté au second tour par le plus grand
talent quoi pierre tu as quelque chose à
rajouter
ouais signe qu ils en parlent d'eux sort
de son jeu poste bas c'est pour moi
c'est le sait le plus gros lots flag qui
va ya voir ça va être sans sa panoplie
de mou en attaque c'est antoine avait
déjà souligné
il avait écouté qu'il avait écrit sur le
sur le site que il était vraiment limité
sur son look main droite
c'est vraiment c'est frappant c'est à ce
qui me laisse un petit peu dubitatif et
qui fait qu'il sera sur marbre pas
drafté très haut c'est qu'il est
toujours toujours ici l'enfant sur son
épaule droite où son épaule gauche
il se retourne constamment sur sa main
droite pour faire un coup c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'il faisait déjà ça en
fiba et à copenhague à où il se faisait
pas contraire à chaque fois mais c'était
vraiment très bas c'est une logique
petite info sur l'entourage du joueur
discutant avec les membres de l'équipe
visiblement il ya un papa un peu trop
omniprésent dans l'entourage de philippe
et rousseff encore un papa un peu trop
omniprésent veut dire aux papas qui nous
écoutent arrêté avec avec vos enfants
ils se débrouillent tout seuls et un
joueur avec un gros caractère comme
comme c'est souvent le cas
comme c'est parfois le cas on va dire
avec les joueurs des balkans mais lui
visiblement webo gros caractères il a
voulu partir de gonzaga
ils savaient où ils allaient savaient
qu'ils auraient du temps de jeu ce pour
ça qu on peut quand même un peu nuancé
le fait qu'il ait réussi à s'adapter ce
que disait pierre c'est à dire que mes
gars l'ex 20 mégas schappler paix est là
et bien c'est une équipe qui est là pour
faire jouer des pros ce texte un peu
comme houlme là où était qu'ils
analysent l'année dernière c'est les
espèces de fermat prospects comme ça il
les met vachement en avant il ya un
probable le top 10 de la chaîne draft
avec nicolas jositsch il ya voilà il ya
énormément de jeunes joueurs dans cette
équipe et qui sont assurés d'avoir du
temps de jeu même s'ils font des bêtises
donc c'est assez même s'il a été élu mvp
donc il ya aucune ya aucun doute sur le
fait qu'il était productif sur le
terrain son équipe et est détenue par
par bio parce que c' est l' agence
lagence kia qui de tous les joueurs de
l'équipe et je confirme sur le sur le le
côté on peut démarrer vite en il est
souvent dans les cols quand il ya des
fautes techniques sont distribués c'est
souvent pour monsieur petru sauf la
tendance à voit que du coude avec les
autres intérieurs et à être dans les
altercations
donc un fort caractère et rythme en tête
l'ultra favorable qui a aussi permis
cette affirmation
c'est cette année et on rappelle vite
fait juste comme ça que à gonzaga ya un
certain de route mis un carré mais qui
va lui prendre de fait un câlin dû
prendre beaucoup de temps de jeu donc il
a senti aussi qu'il avait un peu le feu
au derrière et qu'il fallait peut-être
changer d'orientation et il voulait
prendre les trois points
il est parti parce qu'il voulait plus
jouer pivot l'ajout 4,5
ok donc là je pense qu'on a été complet
sur l'ami philippe et rousseff joueurs
de caractère on va partir avec julien on
va retourner au pays de l'oncle sam on
va dans une fac cher aux camarades à la
new puisqu'il s'agit de san diego state
et tu va nous présenter un ailier c'est
en arrière et jordan sa gueule mais je
commençais par une petite anecdote
cette année il y avait trois joueurs
dont jordan michael qui sortait date du
même du même lycée qui sont retrouvés à
la march madness et détente au thompson
de rügen state david single tonnes qui
joua du ciel et est donc jordan chaque
oeil le bélier
l'arrière ailier de san diego state
university
alors ils ont tous eu des parcours est
différent de celui de chaque oeil à la
marque d'être c'est fini difficilement
j'en parle à chaque à chaque fois qu'on
parle de san diego state parce que ça ça
me fait souffrir quand elle s'associera
qu'il a été dure à encaisser voilà mais
c'est pas seulement une anecdote c'est
que
il ya des matches qui traîne de 7,7
triplettes ont elles eu ce coup là sur
internet et on voit qu'en fait du jardin
dans lequel il a toujours été ce qu'il
est à la fin de ces quatre années à san
diego state c1 seniors donc c'est un
shooteur
c'est un gros shooteur très doué dans
cet exercice donc jordan circle avec 98
90 kg qui dort à 23 ans à la draft roi
ou la draft à seniors et donc son gros
point fort vous l'avez compris c'est de
shoot
il faut sortir des chiffres je pense
pour le comprendre
ces lieux 46 44 89
son pourcentage de points à 3 points
dont 44 % et 4 9% dans s'éprend 179 sur
180 pour ceux qui font des calculs sur
les pourcentages le gros donc un gros
scoreur à trois points c'est sa grosse
force 3 points ou catherine foot dont
44% avec plus de six tentatives cette
année par match donc un gros volume
65% de trousses ou thing donc c'est
vraiment vraiment un gars qui est à
droite sur son geste du même
c'est un geste assez particulier il est
tout de suite il n'y a pas de trop de
temps de préparation il attrape le
ballon il est pratiquement tout de suite
au niveau de sa tête un peu au dessus et
il va y lâche le ballon assez vite c'est
un foot équilibré quelle que soit la
façon dont il m'a donc souhaité que soit
en catch and shoot où après un pool up
et je crois que ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que c'est vraiment c'était un shooteur
de catch and shoot pratiquement exclusif
les chiffres le montrent puisque ils
sont ces trois points sont pratiquement
tous assistés mais cette année il ya eu
des progrès dans dans la création pour
lui quoi on le voit plus tenter des
poules up même à deux points
donc voilà il ya du yak toujours dans
son rôle de souter il ya des progrès
dans le type de chute libre
même si ça reste essentiellement du
calcio alexandre moos pour ce que tu as
vu du foot heure de san diego state
moi ce que j'aime bien faire dans ces
cas là puisqu'il ya aucun doute il s'est
ajouté il sera toujours shooter est ce
que j'aime bien juste chez lui c'est
dans son tir c'est le fait qu'il est une
très bonne base c'est à dire que ça
bouge pas ça bouge pas c'est ce qui lui
permet de shooter vite c'est ce qui lui
permet de shooter au dessus de joueurs
ils font quasiment sa taille qui
pourrait théoriquement le gène est donc
c est intéressant pour pour le niveau
supérieur je veux dire après ce que
j'aime bien faire c'est de regarder les
joueurs un peu du même gabarit qui sont
arrivés tout à l'heure je n'ai pas parlé
mais pète rousseff par exemple très peu
de joueurs de sa taille qui sont pas
hyper dominant au poste dont comme lui
qu'on réussira une billet il n'a
quasiment aucun
donc donc c'est ce qui peut inquiéter
par rapport à cette transition là pour
chaque oeil c'est un peu pareil
il a vraiment aucune 0 création c'est à
dire que cette saison je crois que c'est
6% ou 7% de passes décisives c'est
peanuts c'est à dire que même les
joueurs de fin de chaîne d'habitude ils
ont plus d'un en gros dans son gabarit
avec aussi peu de pourcentage de passes
décisives il y avait danny green voilà
danny green et damian dodson au moment
de l'ordre donc pour moi c'est le
meilleur scénario pour lui c'est damian
dodson damian dodson comment il s'est
imposé en nba en étant très très fort
aux shoots y compris en tirant un peu en
sortie de dribble et en défendant à peu
près correctement je sais pas si chaque
oeil nous faudrait que faudrait demander
à julien j'ai pas l'impression
en tout cas moi sur ce que j'ai vu
qu'ils aient un impact défensif
formidable que ce soit sur l'homme ou
dans la défense d' équipe même s'il est
sérieux il n'y a pas de problème s déçu
c'est sérieux mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il ait le potentiel
voilà pour pour être un chèque minton
russe o'neal dillon brooks tous ces gars
sterling brown tous ces gars qui ont de
son gabarit qui sont imposés en nba et
bat julien passes décisives tout trouvé
la défense lui la défense la défense
mais alors moi j'étais assez dur avec
lui en fait au début je veux dire qu'ils
défendent est pas pas très bien en fait
bon c'est pas un grand défenseur ça ne
sera pas il n'a pas des outils non plus
hein
c'est un gars quand même qu'ils aient
des épées quand même 90 kg il a pas un
physique neutre car c'est ce que je veux
dire
mais il est à verticale il n'est pas il
n'a pas une grande envergure c'est pas
la pâle des outils naturel pour être un
gros défenseur par contre les sérieux
moi je moi je disais qu'il était
appliqué tu vois avec soin
alors c'est peut-être pas un très gros
compliments dire qu'il est appliqué mais
il est toujours dans le truc quoi il est
toujours très attentif à tout ce qui se
passe ils essayent de rester toujours
devant devant sont devant son attaquant
et puis ce que j'ai vu là dernièrement
fait qu'il met beaucoup la main sur le
ballon
en fait c'est un gars qui dès que
quelqu'un passe à côté avec le ballon il
essaye de piquer loi dont il le fait
plutôt bien parce qu'il combat il prend
pas beaucoup de fautes par rapport à ça
mais c'est ils cherchent beaucoup à
gêner les les attaquants donc est-ce que
ça c'est un truc qui pourra faire vos
supérieurs je sais pas en tout cas cela
la défense sera pas sa marque de
fabrique
et juste pour revenir sur la création
comme tu l'as dit qu'on n'a pas son coût
d'usagé 15 à 16% c'est hyper barn pour
un joueur qui joue autant et tient un
rôle aussi prépondérant dans une équipe
ça monte sont utilisés soit vraiment que
exclusive en shooter même au niveau
universitaire et c'est ce que j'ai voulu
dire au début c'est que dès le décès à
midi c'était ça ouais donc effectivement
la marge de voir évoluer et sans la
serrer assez mou petit on va dire mais
chut alors c'est quand même un gros gros
bosseur il ya il a posé du délai de
cette année voir ce qu'ils aient pas
l'année dernière peut-être par par la
force des choses parce qu'ils n'ont plus
leur meneur star comme il est parti à
toronto mais c'est un énorme bosseur
ça c'est la réputation qu'il a acquis au
lycée en ou à la fac même pendant qu vie
il ya des articles trance ourd'hui qui
[Musique]
décrive la façon dont ils travaillent
c'est un travailleur acharné sur son
foot sur notamment le dribble pour
essayer d'améliorer un peu parce que tu
l'as de son choix voilà une honte a pas
entendus sur le shooteur barbu ouais je
vais commencer par un point inutile
physiquement parlant j'ai pas vu qu'il
met un coup de boule en qu'il ya un fond
incroyable ce mec là même soit pour un
entraînement c'est quand même pratique
ça c'était pour le point inutile
pour parler du joueur effectivement ça
c'est un vrai vrai shooteur ce que
j'aime bien à damas là tu l'a évoqué
rapidement c'est qu'il est dans une
équipe qui a perdu quand même beaucoup
de son personnel et il est passé de la
4è 5è options offensives à la à celui
qui finalement a pris le plus de volume
de tir devant matt mitchell qui londres
a nié en prenez plus que lui par exemple
donc c'est un mec qui est quand même pu
plonger dans le volume tout en gardant
des pourcentages excellent quand on
parle de 46% à 3 points avec le
tentative qui prend 91 % aux lancers
francs c'est quand même super bien et
puis ben je crois que vous avez à
pourquoi de dix jours le reste qu'est ce
qu'on va attendre de lire une bille est
qu'ils puissent qui puisse mettre dedans
et ça passera
en fait si je dois garder en gros par
rapport aux mêmes gags que lui dans la
draft on tente de position suis pas sûr
de le prendre dans ma draft parce qu'il
est unidimensionnel par contre c'est un
gars qui peut en pour moi en ligue b et
c à trouver trouver une place juste par
ailleurs le fait la qualité de son bras
cou très bien moi ce que j'avais noté
chez lui c'est ça son unique tentative
de dunk et qu'il a raté en plus cette
année et le fait aussi qu'il ya
quasiment pas de foot près du cercle ou
que pour lui la peinture doit un peu
brûlé les pieds donc ça donne un petit
peu une idée aussi du genre de voir que
que c'est même sans avoir beaucoup vu de
dommage de lui
messieurs dernier prospects on part avec
hugues avec un coach peut-être le coach
peut plus hipster de l'acier beau but
this on va parler d'un procès qui a
plutôt bien marché dans une éthique a
plutôt séduit aussi globalement c'est à
toi
ouais on va parler de dérive qu'elle
gère le pivot de west virginia
university et c'est un mec
qui a eu un parcours hyper intéressant
parce que ça a beaucoup évolué donc
actuellement là il sort de troisième et
c'est un pivot de m 0 800 15 kilos une
envergure de 120 cm qu'une belle au
regard du rhône à un bon bb1 bien
physique lorsqu'il sort du lycée
il est considéré que plus comme ailier
ailier fort il fait de maître 0,3 il
fait 90 kg et en fait moi la force des
choses il va rajouter 20 kg sur ce corps
et c'est quand même 20 kg à ses muscles
que je n'ai pas par exemple
et en plus de ça west virginia ils
commencent l'année faut le rappeler avec
oscar che bout et qui est le gros joueur
de l'équipe en tant que pivot directe
que le coeur qui fout 4,5 à côté de lui
et en 3e miles mcbride et l'équipe de
weather gina va perdre chez bouygues qui
va finalement fait il ya des problèmes à
nos l'université il ya des alarmes prem
relationnel etc avec le coach avec
l'équipe et tout est il par le jouer
mais par de l'université pour jouer à
kentucky l'an prochain et donc toutes dû
être remodelé et celui qui en a le plus
profité peut-être avec mcbride ces
calvaires concernant son jeu on a un
joueur là qu'il ya un jeu qui est
quasiment orienté sur du poste bas qui a
appris à faire du pick and roll au fur
et à mesure parce que c'était pas le cas
du tout aux débuts dans l'équipe des
monteilles n'hésitez pas beaucoup de
pick and roll et qui va dominer balle en
main au panier et avec ses fondamentaux
de pied ses épaules
il va mettre vraiment la grosse pression
sur les défenseurs adverses avec des
gros coups des pôles dit vas y tourne
très bien
un des deux côtés des épaules sur les
deux épaules et finit très très bien
sous le cercle comme ça le point négatif
pour lui c'est le tir il a une absence
de tiers qui est très problématique
on le voit pas non plus pouvoir poser la
balle au niveau du sol pour pouvoir
aller jusqu'au cercle de piles postaux
donc là actuellement si on doit acheter
en attaque que le vert c'est vraiment
dans un rôle rolmen très athlétique très
très dynamique et qui va finir quasiment
uniquement sous le cercle voilà ça c'est
pour l'attak
alexandre tu l'as vu mais j'ai envie de
te dire un peu malgré toi qu'est ce que
tu as pu lui trouver comme qualité c'est
un cauchemar je n'ai quasiment rien chez
ce joueur à part le fait qu'ils soient
effectivement très puissant j'aime pas
son attitude
j'aime pas si on reste sur la tacc le
fait qu'ils ne progressent pas du tout
aux tirs c'est à dire ça quand même sa
troisième saison
il a progressé ni autour du cercle ni à
mi distance
il avait fait un petit pic l'an passé
retourne à 30 % ni aux lancers francs
ni à trois points n'a aucune progression
ajoute donc comment ça veut dire que tu
as peut-être pas demain et je suis
peut-être un peu dur mais je juge même
en europe je vois pas où il peut aller
des règles leur jeu vraiment je trouve
que c'est un joueur qu'un super physique
mais c'est à peu près tout quoi et
peut-être que l'état d'esprit et qui est
que j'ai juste ressenti par flash en
regardant jouer joue dans le dans le
fait qu'ils progressent très peu alors
moi je vais relancer luc parce que moi
quand je les ai vus vous et il m'a fait
penser à avoir de mississippi state
c'était vraiment ce genre de profil de
deux gros mec qui vont au charbon et qui
donne des gros coups d épaule mais après
à côté ça les mains c'est pas vraiment
ça quoi non mais c'est pas un esthète
clairement on n'est pas heureux sur de
l'esthétique en fait si j'en parle
aujourd'hui des avec le sait pas ce
qu'il reste comme la dernière fois pour
un mmorpg seca mais qui reste cotée qui
a encore voilà une belle valeur sur pas
mal de moc américain on le retrouve
souvent dans les top 100 et c'est un
joueur qu on attaque qui va provoquer
beaucoup de lancers francs alors il est
pas efficace en se promenant provoque
beaucoup et j'aime bien regarder les
joueurs qui restent puissants pour ce
niveau annecy est là et en fait encore
cette situation à me projeter sur ce mec
là je me dis
on va pas lui demander de jouer au poste
bas on va pas lui demander de faire du
mi distance à ce niveau là tu vas juste
demandé de rouler pour de l'offensif et
de prendre du rebond est un excellent
rebondeur dans le placement et dans le
temps là dans la prise en fait et du
coup vous regardez à d'anelka ford qui
marche bien alors je compare pas
exactement les profils et je me dis ok
pourquoi pas et je dois regarder jour
d'autres profils à peu près similaire au
niveau du renne je me dis ok pourquoi
pas des règles leurs épices et surtout
défensivement qui m'a montré des choses
qui me disent quand il y est ça peut
intéresser des d'hygiène et si je dois
rentrer dans la défense
c'est sa capacité vanille vallorbe allez
on est parti en lion et lugos c'est sa
capacité à défendre au périmètre malgré
le premier abord on se dit ok il aa il a
l'air assez lent il sort pas souvent un
périmètre dans la défense des loisirs
dynea et puis à des matches comme ça où
tu le vois des sortir au périmètre
orienté et amener jusqu'au panier et
tenir le cap à se faire prendre
il a tenu des gardes il a tenu quelques
unes hingham il à moi j'ai pas vu
quelques d'une gamme sont toutes les
attaques
la prix je dirais que le vert lui mettre
un panier dessus et c'est un gars y
voilà qui est assez qui est guerrier qui
va rentrer de la puissance physique qui
va tenir et ça j'aime mieux sa
polyvalence là-dessus défensive alors
tout mouvement un bon défenseur et en
même temps il n'a pas des stats non plus
de gros protecteur de cercle si je me
trompe pas il doit être à peu près un
coût par masque n'est en rien
d'extraordinaire pour un petit veau
comment tu expliques sa part après ça
revient aussi beaucoup avec la défense
de de sa fac qui va essayer non plus
d'aller tout le temps au bloc c'est
qu'on enferme beaucoup c'est une défense
qui oriente énormément match mc brède
mis une grosse pression sur le porteur
de ballon donc c'est le petit 1 le garde
et des raies que le vert va amener avec
lui il l'étouffé
et souvent c'est une défensive a
provoqué beaucoup de deux pertes de
balle
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'on n'a pas
énormément de contre et c'est un joueur
aussi tu vois qui va pas alors il peut
faire des fautes mais il va pas non plus
être l'alpha bbl trop souvent et c'est
un mec sur lequel son équipe a pu
compter malgré le manque d'intérieur
d'arrière donc ça j'aime bien aussi que
ce soit pas là en gros naïfs qui sautent
partout
et qui entraient d'arrière-droit nba ne
peut jamais jouer sur le temps de jeu
qu'on lui donne alors alex est ce que
défensivement il trouve un petit peu de
grâce à tes yeux
moi j'ai pas vu autant de matches q donc
je peux dire que oui sur certaines
séquences effectivement il m'a il m'a
agréablement surpris mais le problème
c'est que c'est un junior donc c'est
quand même sa troisième saison à la fac
et qu'au niveau de la constance ses
katas moi je les ai vus j'ai regardé
franchement j'ai regardé trois matches
de suite j'ai regardé trois matches
ouyahia
j'avais l'impression j'exagère peut-être
mais une action sur cinq ou dix il
abandonne au mieux il vraiment ils
abandonnent c'est à dire qu'il va il va
faire sans clause out et après ils se
cassent ils aiment les bras et machin il
se casse et ça je trouve ça
catastrophique comme attitude pour un
joueur de troisième année surtout dans
cette équipe où hugues l'a dit ça défend
dur on a des consignes assez strict où
il lui vraiment pas enfin j'ai rarement
eu l'impression de voir un joueur
positif pour son équipe
il y avait une super il y avait un super
contexte pour lui cette saison avec
plein de shooter il aurait pu faire
vachement plus de dégâts offensivement
ils auraient pu montrer beaucoup plus
aussi défensivement je pense pour moi le
fait qu'ils progressent pas dans ce
contexte là avec le départ de tchimou et
qu'il avait plus dans les pattes
donc c'était quand même c'est quand même
un avantage aux cartes chez boyer qui
est partie en cours de saison qu'il y
aura quelqu'un qui la semaine prochaine
je joue je comprends pas pourquoi il n'a
pas plus progresser pour finir sur son
profil si on se base sur les stades
avancés
les comparaisons sont les meilleurs que
j'ai trouvée puisque la plupart c'est
sombre inconnu
jordan jordan hill je trouve ça pas
inintéressant même s'ils ont la haine
billet d'aujourd'hui je sais pas ce que
donnerait giordani et tomasz robinson
qui lui avait un petit pet au casque
aussi
dimanche
hugues valley ouais être tu penses pas
aussi parce que ce soit je me suis posé
la question ne regardant que pour un
joueur changer autant de systèmes parce
que vraiment on ne peut pas du tout
comparé les deux équipes de west
virginia avec thébaux est libre et c'est
pas aussi hyper performant alors le
joueur progresse pas beaucoup c'est
clair on voit pas de mal de dos comme
utiliser de progrès dans le jeu dans la
finition et tout ça et engrais landrais
pour ce que tu l'achètes 1 pour le plein
raison pour laquelle tu l'achète en nba
tu ne donnera pas de le faire
il va jusqu'à lui demander de faire du
robot de courir en transition parce
qu'il va être plus rapide que les
intérieurs adverses et de finir après en
gros un écran parce qu'il pose des très
bons écrans et que du crêt du décalage
est juste de finir par menace verticale
en vrai c'est un joueur sur le petit va
coûter très peu cher pour une équipe
dans un rôle de rotation intérieure qui
va jouer huit dix minutes et pour le
contexte des types au début de l'année
il est en tant que joueur de pipeau ce
taux qui doit faire des posts au poste
bas pour pourtier bout et avec tout le
monde dans le cas des cartes à côté et
d'un coup il devient je fais que du pick
and roll que du pick and roll et je
pense que pour un jour ça peut être
aussi très compliqué de s'adapter en
plein milieu de saison comme ça c'est un
rôle à la gillespie c'est possible de le
draft et mais je le vois pas assez
protecteur de cercle pour ça même si
c'est pas dans je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est pas dans la culture de l'équipe
etc
on préfère prendre la faute offensive
plutôt que de sauter au contre mais
je j'ai pas l'impression qui saute très
haut j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
une menace exceptionnel dans un rôle
j'ai pas l'impression que le les
capacités athlétiques soit adéquate par
rapport à ce qu'est ce que peut être un
gillespie qui est à peu près dans le
même moule mais costaud pas il est
peut-être un peu moins grands guides et
voilà qu'il ya moins de diamants de qi
basket
ouais que tu dis tout ça me ça me voilà
ça ne fait pas frétiller julien on n'a
pas entendu encore sur notre ami d'eric
holder
mais tu m'as piqué ma question je
voulais me fut question sur le contre
mais parce que je me demandais tu vois
si son pour la projection quoi est-ce
que ça défonce les suisses seraient
suffisantes pour 1 par rapport à son
manque total de foot quoi
et sinon je me suis posé la question de
son moteur mais avec c'est à moitié
répondu parce que je trouvais que il ya
des moments où justement pour les romans
il a une énergie
il pousse tout le monde mais c'est
énorme et paul donc il ya des pauses
beaucoup d'énergie à prendre ce qui est
complètement parfois ils à avoir froid
vous vous demandez si c'était moi je
n'étais pas là pour poser la question de
la motivation je vous demander s'ils
n'étaient pas ce n'était pas le
sébastien chabal de west virginia tu
vois le gars qui a un physique de fouet
qui a qui arrivent pas à tenir sur la
sur la longueur mais je sais pas moi
j'ai pas trop de réponses sur le sur le
mental du jeu aussi pas assez creusé tu
vas dans les attendus dans les
interviews et tout mais j'ai senti une
équipe au global un apparat mcbride qui
se monte mais une équipe dans le
mal-être au général donc après faudrait
regarder plus tard et et voir ce que ce
qui pourra sortir peut-être des idées
insider mais sur son rôle par exemple tu
aurais tu me disais qu'il estime sans
votre tête
tu vois le rôle d'un kember ch j'ai
regardé
le rôle d'un qu'est ce que je peux avoir
derrière davis ce genre de gala quoi que
tu as vraiment ou même en un kyle au
queen par exemple donc des bons gros
bébé de la viande de rota que tu draft
où tu draft pas personnellement dans mon
top 60 il y est pas je sors du top 60
mais c'est un mec que je peux voir
choper une place comme ça derrière et
juste pour son rô le de de viande à à
mettre dans la peinture
messieurs l'heure est grave
vous savez c'est l'heure de la voix de
garde et je crois que alex un problème
de taille
écoute la wild card ça va être une gare
de philosophie de draft puisque j'ai eu
la chance d'être d'être invité par les
amis qui font le podcast c'est une pour
un podcast vidéo qui parle des toronto
raptors les toronto raptors ont terminé
leur saison donc maintenant ils
s'intéressent à nos avants d un petit
peu et du coup ils m'ont demandé mon
avis sur sur la saison qu'avait fait le
rookie ce que c'était dans les attentes
et c'est donc la roue qui sont à jon
harris freddy gillespie nous devons
parler malakite flynn et j'ai regardé un
petit peu parce que je suis pas j'ai pas
vraiment regardé les raptors cette
saison à vrai dire j'ai regardé un petit
peu les matchs de malakite flynn où il a
fait de la stat surtout en fin de saison
puisque ça tank et un peu il y avait un
peu de il y avait du temps de jeu j'ai
regardé les matchs giannaris j'ai
regarder les stats avancé et je me suis
dit c'est marrant mais je pense que pour
le futur de cette équipe je préfère
avoir giannaris comme elle accueille
flynn mon raisonnement est le suivant
mal à griffin a été d'une efficacité à
ces terribles pour sa première année ce
qui est souvent le cas chez les roux qui
donc c'est pas grave mais je pense que
c'est quelque chose de très difficile à
améliorer et j'ai un problème de taille
parce que je pense que c'est juste parce
qu'il est petit en fait est que moi dans
ma philosophie c'est exactement pour
cette raison
que je ne vais pas drafté quelqu'un sauf
capacités exceptionnelles mais un mètre
88 9
ça me paraît être la limite et lui ils
étaient 1 85 je crois que je crois qu'il
va en 85 à peu près parce que parce que
ça dd impact à la fois défensif évident
et d'autant plus en playoffs surtout si
vous n'êtes pas un mec qui fait un
kilomètre de large x 5 km d'épaisseur et
savas avoir d impact offensif aussi
malakai flynn par exemple il l'a très
très mal shooté même sur catch and shoot
lorsqu'il y avait un défenseur à moins
de chez plus quelles sont les stats
avancé nba mais je crois que c'est à
moins de 27 pieds donc moins de deux
mètres
on voyait tout de suite son efficacité
baisser c'est pas il faut pas être un
génie pour se dire bah tiens parce qu'en
fait il est petit peu pas shooté au
dessus des gens donc quand il ya
quelqu'un qui est devant lui avec ses
grands bras même si un space in game by
nba et là ça ça rentre pas donc c'était
simplement pour dire qu'il y avait une
espèce de tendance ces dernières années
à dire mais tant qu un joueur c'est bien
jouer au basket il a un gros puis y est
bien je préfère draft est un joueur qui
sait bien jouer au basket km 85 15
joueurs qui s'est moins bien jouer qui
permet de 95 et 98
je pense que cette tendance est un peu
surcoté et qu'elle a été faite en
réaction à ce qui se passait dans les
années 2000 où on disait du can teach
size ce qui est toujours vrai et on
draft est des mecs qui faisait 2 mètres
28 mai qui pouvait pas bouger et je
pense que en fait la taille c'est
important est-ce que ce raisonnement
s'applique aussi où squattent tu as
parlé de meneur est ce que c'est valable
pour les autres postes aussi ce que tu
gars cette même philosophie ou août et
un peu plus partagés en fait
c'est pas ce n'est pas une question de
meneur c'est juste un mec qui fait un
moins d'1 88
j'ai pas de problème avec un mec qui va
être juste en catch and shoot est
capable de faire des passes et qui fait
1 92 13 je prends cette curie par
exemple qui est un excellent joueur nba
alors évidemment on va me sortir des
contre exemples des prés devant 9 lite
il ya des giants bronson encore une fois
ça c'est des joueurs qui sont ultra
épais ont déjà des longs bras et me
semblent pour leur taille et qui sont
épais quoi qui peuvent défendre plus
haut que leur position et se crée de
l'espace grâce à leur puissance physique
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la cafrine en
l'occurrence même si j'ai rien contre
lui et je lui souhaite tout le meilleur
c'est pas le problème mais mais du coup
non c'est pas une question de poste et
ses yeux voilà je joue aujourd'hui c'est
la mode des grands meneurs c'est pareil
je comprends pas trop pourquoi c'est la
mode des grands meneurs à part le fait
qu'ils puissent voir mieux le jeu mais
mais du coup pour en finir là dessus si
tu fais moins d'1 90 pour moi tu tu n'es
pas efficace que tu es la balle en main
ou que tu ne l'est pas c'est que tu es
moins dangereux de toute façon et c'est
comme quand tu fais plus de deux mètres
15 témoins mobile donc tu es moins
impactant sur le jeu messieurs est-ce
que vous avez des questions par rapport
à cette invite ronchi nombre loge
largement un peu austère condotte une
longue et qui va qui va se glisser on le
voit de plus en plus etc l'idéal massa
d'avoir 5 m 2 de mai 0,3 sur le terrain
et c'est à peu près ça puisque les
équipes parce que beaucoup d qui peut
essayer de viser ses deux de la
polyvalence de switch au lait et on va
supprimer au fur et à mesure les petits
même si certains certains résistent
encore et en commentaire on le disait
avec julien là j'arrive cooper j'arrive
tout paris vers lille va arriver avec
son petit mètre 88
et comme il va provoquer 43 fautes par
match et envoyé 48 loeb ça va aller quoi
absolument je suis absolument d'accord
et justement c'est pour ça que j'ai bien
précisé au début de mon propos sauf
capacités extraordinaires
j'ai coupé elle
le texte contient effectivement on
parlera plus tard du meneur assez
fantastique deux dents cassées peut
jouer quand même messieurs ainsi
s'achève l'épisode 4 de dobbs alex
pierre julien hughes
merci beaucoup merci à vous nous suivent
toujours plus nombreux n'hésitez pas à
nous faire des retours à poser vos
questions et comme le veut la formule
liker et partagez l'occasion pour moi de
vous rappeler qu envergure c'est aussi
un site envergure prince et on vous y
trouverez les b-boys des articles les
podcasts mais aussi des scouting ne les
portent sur plus de 50 ans ont été mises
à jour ces derniers jours donc allez-y
on se retrouve d'ici un mois pour un
nouvel épisode d'honneur dogs on est
loin de vous bye
[Musique]